if you like Necco wafers the original
candy wafer yeah that's a category that
really took off there's no need to watch
this video you're going to get screwed
no matter what and same goes if you like
those nasty little orange and black
candies save yourself some time don't go
trick-or-treating just eat random crap
you find on the floor and now we begin
step one identifying your trading
partner children under the age of five
are legally protected that's because of
Becky's law named after a Wisconsin girl
who traded her entire stash for a box of
good & plenty that her brother had
convinced her were a unicorn egg she
cried for three and a half years
children between the ages of five and
seven are allowed a thirty second trade
back grace period this also applies to
the elderly if you have friends or
siblings with any of the following
traits they make ideal trading partners
if you don't you'll have to get crafty
start by determining the flavor affinity
of your opponent there are three basic
classes and each one has a weakness be
warned that a classic strategy is to
pretend that you're in the fruit and
sour category while executing the
Smarties gambit for a full-sized
Snickers if you'd like to download a pdf
version of this chart please look in
your but if your opponent says that they
like special darks be kind to them
they're probably going to be your boss
someday likewise if they express
interest in any of the oral fixation
candies like wax lips paper dots candy
cigarettes or pop rocks keep track of
them they're gonna be fun to hang out
with in college before they drop out
step 2 pre trade organization and
preparation loose candy corn should be
placed with your pennies they're equally
worthless under the new health law
ripped or unwrapped candy falls under
the protection of pre-existing condition
and although they lose value you cannot
exclude them from trading dum-dums
should be organized in complete sets not
by individual flavor unless of course
you have three or more root beers which
can be set aside lump your three
musketeers together with your Milky
Way's to ferret out people that don't
know the difference most likely they'll
confuse crackles and mr. good bars to
hide your Mary Jane's banana-flavored
Taffy's and any short lasting
Bubblegum's under a pile of whoppers
goobers caramel cubes and red hots be
prepared to offer the full stack as an
all-or-none trade for a Charleston true
or greater
although nerds are technically inert pop
rocks they should be placed in their own
category unfortunately butterfingers
Almond Joy and mounds should be set
aside for the mom and dad tax note that
there is growing support to repeal the
mom and dad tax as it hurts honest candy
disclosure and might lead children to
stop trick-or-treating
all together if possible avoid major
transactions until after the election
and raisins should be burned and then
peed on by your dog part three classic
strategies avoid anyone who suggests
dumping all the candy in a pile and
rationing it out based on hunger they
are Marxists john maynard keynes
suggested taking 40% of the candy from
the children with the most burying it in
the ground and then giving the candy
poor children jobs digging it up or of
course you can try the classic approach
whatever you choose remember that pixie
sticks Twizzlers and Smarties are your
workhorses and fifth avenues are better
than hundred grand and as for anyone who
gave you an apple don't worry they're
going to hell
you